we kind of started talking offline about
neanderthals
uh do you have something interesting
genetically biologically
in terms of difference between uh
neanderthal
and like the different branches of human
evolution that
you find fascinating neanderthals are
only one of about five branches
that we are pretty confident about one
branches of
of out of africa events so basically
there's neanderthals
there's denisovans what is the evidence
for denisovans
one tiny little fragment of one
pinky from one cave
in siberia recent relatively recently
discovered
right less than 10 years ago yeah and
those are like little folks right
no no no no no that's yet another one
though homo florence's it had the little
folks
in sort of indonesia but then uh the
nissans are basically another branch
that we only know about genetically from
that one bone
and eventually we realize that it's one
of the three major branches along with
neanderthal modern human
and denisovan and then that one branch
has now resurfaced in many different
areas and we kind of know about
the gene flow that happened in between
them so when i was reading my greek
mythology
it was talking about the age of the
heroes these eras
of human like you know precursors
that were wiped out by zeus or by all
kinds of wars and so forth
like the titans and the you know it's
it's ridiculous
to sort of read these stories as a kid
because you're like oh yeah whatever
and then you're growing up and you're
like whoa layers and layers of
human-like ancestors
and who knows if those stories were
inspired by bones that they found that
kind of looked human-like
but were not quite human-like who knows
if stories of dragons were inspired by
bones of dinosaurs
basically this archaeological evidence
has been there
and has probably entered the folk
imagination
migrated into the stories but it's not
that far you know removed from what
actually happened
of massive wars of wiping out
neanderthals
as humans are modern humans are
populating um
you know europe do you think do you
think what killed the neanderthals
and all those other branches is human
conflict or is it genetic conflict so
is it uh us humans being
the opposite of altruistic towards each
other or
is it uh some other
uh competition at some other level like
as we're discussing
yeah so if you look at a lot of human
traits today
they're probably not that far removed
from the human traits that got us where
we are now
so you know this whole tribalism
you know you're my sports team or
you're my you know political party or
you're my
you know tiny little village and
therefore
you know if you're from that other
village i hate you but as soon as we're
both
in the major city i can't believe we're
from the same region my friend
come here my and like two neighboring
countries fighting and as soon as
they're off in another country they're
like oh i can't believe that right so
it's it's kind of funny like this
tribalism is nonsensical in many ways
it's like
cognitive incongruent that basically we
like
kin and selection for for
sort of liking kin is hugely
advantageous genetically
probably across all kinds of organs all
across all kinds of life yeah
so so basically if you now transport
that to
the sort of humans arriving in europe
and neanderthals are everywhere what are
you going to do you're going to kill
them off
you know there's this battle for
territory and these battle for they're
not like
us we have to get rid of them so
basically there's a
you know very interesting mix there but
and yet and yet
when you look at the genetics there's
tons of gene flow between them
so basically you know love romance
between
you know you have tribes but love uh
uh spans uh the gap between the
different tribes it's wrong somebody's
julia it's a cross species boundaries
sneaks away from the village but before
even before the out of africa there's
you know within africa's election
which was probably massive battles of
larger and larger tribes
selecting for our social networking
and savviness and uh you know probably
all our conspiracy theory genes are
you know dating back from then and you
know it's so there's a lot of
this mischievousness in the history of
human evolution
that unfortunately still present in you
know many ugly forms today
but probably contributed to our success
as a species
in wiping out other species it just
sucks that
uh we don't have neighboring species
that are
you know intelligent like us uh
that but yet very different than us
so we have like you know dogs or wolves
i guess
uh co-evolved they they figured out
how to uh neighbor up with humans in a
friendly way and collaborate and
it develop describing this as if the
wolves made a choice
it's possible that the wolves never had
to say that basically humans were just
so
overpowering that they had captive
wolves
and then at every generation killed off
eight of the nine pups
and only kept the one that was milder uh
humans and it only takes a few
generations to then sort of have pups
that are really mild
and so the neanderthals weren't useful
in the same way that would i don't know
if it's a question of useful they were
probably super useful
my thinking is that they were
scary that basically something that
almost resembles you
yeah is something that you try to
eliminate first
it's too close yeah and uh speaking of
um you know species that are intelligent
and sort of
what's left of evolution it is a shame
exactly like you say that so many
different amazing life forms were
extinct
and the kind of boring ones remained
so if you look at dinosaurs i mean the
diversity
that they had if you look at sub you
know like
there's just so many different lineages
of
life that were just abruptly killed
and yet out of that death emerged you
know many
new kinds of really awesome lineages
you